LEGO has many exciting ranges
including 'Star Wars', 'Harry Potter' and 'Indiana Jones'.
Now we're proud to announce a new range,
one of the most exciting and action-packed ever:
LEGO 'Philosophy'!
Inside the box you'll find everything you need to get your exclusive philosophy world up and running.
Your exclusive philosopher comes with... no accessories whatsoever.
Their main purpose is to be made to sit in the corner and think.
They do nothing.
They make no money.
They can't operate machinery.
They couldn't drive something like this
or fly that.
But they do have a purpose:
they take our thoughts, which are often lying in a tangled mess,
and they order them into beautiful manageable chunks
so that we can hopefully understand ourselves and the difficulties facing us a little better.
Think of them as the cleaners and the rangers of our minds.
Every LEGO collection, and every society, should have a figure of these philosophers somewhere in the background
ready to clean up our thoughts.